of course it will be a relaxation no
one's expecting it to end you know we're
gonna have to coexist with this virus
for four I think many months if not
potentially years but we've got to find
a way forward and and that does mean
you're relaxing as much you can running
the economy hot you could say in a way
that you you you try are trying to take
into account not just the sort of
necessity to control the virus but also
the wider impact on society those those
job losses those opportunities for Gonz
particularly for younger people
the rise in domestic violence child
abuse your mental health cases you know
all of that needs to be taken to account
when you talk about running the economy
hot do you mean that we need to run it
close to the reproduction rate of one of
the disease I open it up as much as
possible to try and limit that longer to
economic damage yeah I think we just
need to as well as you're listening of
course of the scientific advice and and
also ajik take into account that the
scientists themselves sometimes don't
quite agree on what the best way forward
is but as well as listening to the
scientists we also need to as we are you
would think carefully about the impact
on the rest of society in the economy
and jobs and and wider social impacts
and that does mean I think that when it
comes to opening up you want to go as
far and as quick as you can there's
obviously been some debate as to the
pace of lifting the lockdown what do you
want to see then next week it's a bare
minimum what I would like to sort of
feel is that ministers are going as far
as they possibly can taking into account
all the factors not just the the science
but the impact on the economy as well
president Trump said that Americans may
have to accept a greater loss of life as
a price of getting the economy moving
this is these are his words
he was asked well this some people be
affected bad and he said yes but we have
to get our country open and we have to
get it open soon is does he have a point
there no I think many countries and it's
not just the others of the United States
yeah the car European friends
they're grappling with this about what
exactly is the right response if you go
too fast if you open up your way too
fast the numbers might rise again in
terms of deaths and so you need to be
wary of that public need to know don't
they that there are really brutal
trade-offs in all of this all the
choices are horrible choices but that we
might have to live with some level of
mortality around kovat 19 some level of
death in our society one day there'll be
a vaccine but I don't think anyone can
say you when that will be it could be
months could be years away you know who
knows and you know I hope of course it's
a lot sooner but in the meantime we need
to just plan to live with this for
example we know now that the the
mortality rate of younger people let's
say under the age of 45 is a lot lot
lower than others and it might be the
case that in the future we can find a
way that we focus our protection on
those that are most vulnerable those
that have underlying the illnesses but
give more freedom to let's say younger
people so they can get on with their
lives at the same time help the rest of
us by rebuilding our economy which
benefits everyone so do you think that
one option could be in terms of trying
to open the economy but protect life
that basically the vulnerable in society
in the over 70s might have to have a
different set of rules to everyone else
and that that would be a sacrifice that
they have to live with we're learning
all the time but we shouldn't rule out
an option that focuses on protecting the
most vulnerable and but gives more
freedom to others so we are going to
have to treat different age groups
differently you may have to it's sort of
like some people making sacrifices for
others just as in everyone made a
sacrifice and locking down to protect
life I mean these are things we all have
to do together as a society well we the
I in its being tough for all of us the
last few weeks and but I think one of
the things that it we certainly as a
society you
you I think we can feel very proud of is
that how everyone has come together
they've done their beard whether that's
by staying at home but particularly I
think the health workers that have
basically put their lives at risk so
they can look after the rest of us and
and that is something I think we'll
never forget and we want to find I think
as a country away to recognize the
sacrifices made by those in health in
particular but more broadly in emergency
services which leads me to the next
obvious question do you think the
government should give Nasus a pay rise
well I think that nurses doctors should
be recognized and rewarded in some way
and that is certainly one way to do it
but if you aren't gonna give a pay rise
you also want to be sure as a government
that you can sustain it year for your on
a permanent basis for many many years
how on earth are we gonna pay for it all
in the end many things will change as a
result of this crisis one thing that
shouldn't change is our understanding of
the economic model that leads to the
highest growth rate possible which is
still going to be a free enterprise low
tax your competitive economy this is the
best way to make sure that we are
earning enough as a country to pay for
the public services we all rely on it
was true then and it's true now and
that's going to be critical that we
stick with the economic model that we
know that works so in terms of tax rises
you don't think that there should be any
tax rises to help pay for the debt that
we're piling up I think we should try to
avoid tax rises simply because it's
self-defeating you know if you have
taxes that are that are rising
especially if they rise significantly
after this crisis it will strangle any
economic recovery I mean the other way
you manage that is you try and constrain
public spending do you think we will
have to return to some sort of austerity
you can only spend what you've got you
know that you can you can't
continuously sustainable you keep boring
and so we will have to bring finances
under control but again I think the the
best way to keep spending what we need
on the public services with NHS its
schools all these things that we rely on
is to focus on the growth
of the economy and not higher taxes
finally this is your first television
interview since you resigned as
Chancellor in February be asked to suck
all your advisers you just said I'm not
prepared to do that and you decided that
you'd rather leave that job than work
under those conditions do you regret
that decision now no your I've said what
I wanted to say about that I made a
statement to Parliament I thought that
was the right way to set out when your
why I left government I don't regret
anything and you know I I want this
government to do incredibly well and to
succeed and I'm gonna continue to help
in every way that I can